[Music]
Hello, happy Wednesday, November 18,
Andrés González greets you and these are the
most relevant news of the day. A
fire in the north of the state of
Nevada destroyed several houses in the
southwest of the kingdom. Hundreds of residents
were evacuated and the governor has already
declared a  A state of emergency for the
area according to the kingdom's fire chief
at least 500 homes remain under
threat from the fire that broke out yesterday
in the Cal Friend Range neighborhood so
far the flames have ravaged more than
1,500 acres but no injuries have been reported.
and according to the special command
of the southern nevada health district,
coronavirus vaccines could be
available as soon as
december and they are preparing to
administer them this coming Saturday a
group of school nurses
together with pharmacists will carry out a
exercise in eldorado
high school training is to
execute the process of how it is going to
administering the vaccine dose when
it arrives in las vegas
and former secretary of state and
democrat rush miller said he
plans to fight efforts for
a second race for
the so ce district county commission race
only ten votes separate thousands of
his republican challenger
anthony states the commission approved the
results of all races
except extra because the
registrar of elections yo gloria in
his report said that if there were
enough anomalies to cast doubt on
the election the house of  commissioners
said they will meet in december to
decide whether or not there will be a special pick
in this race
the nba draft is tonight and
chat bay de las vegas is expected to
hear his name in the second round
tyler is 6-foot-7 and  He dropped out of
Las Vegas' Hype High School to go to
California for his senior year. He also played
for the University of Colorado
last season.
let's see the extended forecast
today it will be a cloudy day with a maximum
of 78 degrees but with strong winds
as in the graph already for Saturday
and Sunday there will be a drop in
temperatures but pleasant to
enjoy the weekend have
an excellent  bill informed andrés
gonzález and that was about the
news now in spanish
[Music]